Google just dropped NanoBanana 2. This
is by far the best image generator and
editor we have right now. This is way
faster than the previous version,
NanoBanana Pro. Plus, they claim it has
much better world understanding,
consistency, and prompt adherence. So,
in this video, I'm going to go over all
the crazy things that you can do with
it, and I'm going to compare this with
the previous version of Nano Banana.
Plus, I'm going to go over its specs and
performance benchmarks and where you can
use it for free. Let's jump right in.
Now, before I start showing you some
demos, it's worth mentioning that we
already have a ton of image models that
can do simple stuff like colorizing and
restoring old photos or removing
watermarks or changing the camera angle
of a photo or changing the pose of
someone, doing close swapping and all
that fun stuff. This is already really
easy to do and all the top models can
ace these tests already. So, in this
video, I'm mainly going to show you some
extremely challenging prompts to really
test the limits of Nano Banano 2. All
right. Now, one of the main advantages
of Nano Banana is it has such a good
world understanding of pretty much any
famous celebrity or existing character
in the world. We can prompt it to make a
photo of a ton of celebrities all in the
same shot. For example, here I have
Johnny Depp, Jackie Chan, Taylor Swift,
Tom Hanks, The Rock, Michael Jackson,
Oprah, Blackpink, Cristiano Ronaldo,
Elon Musk, Beyonce, Leonardo, Raana,
Brad Pitt, Selena Gomez, Will Smith,
Lady Gaga, Justin Bieber, Barack Obama,
and Ariana taking a group selfie. And
here is what we got from Nano Banana 2.
You can see all the characters are
actually present, and they do look like
the actual celebrity. Now, because
there's so many characters jam-packed
into this one shot, the resolution isn't
great. So, you can see like some noise
in the facial details of some of these
characters, but overall, it's not bad.
And then for your reference, here is the
generation from Nano Banana Pro. You can
see the photo isn't really as coherent.
Plus, it messed up Black Pink. That
looks really weird. Anyways, as you can
see, in terms of just the realism and
coherence of the photo, this generation
from the new Nano Banana looks much
better than Nano Banana Pro, which kind
of looks like they're all just glued
together. This doesn't look very
realistic. Now, in addition to realistic
people, this also has an extremely good
world knowledge of cartoon, anime, and
2D characters. So for example here we
have Levi Acriman Ana Forger Rick and
Morty Gohan Alons Chica Fujiada Emmelia
Gojo Nzuko Curto Kenny Bart Simpson and
Snow White taking a selfie. Notice that
these are from a ton of different anime
shows and American cartoons Disney
characters. And some of these aren't
even like the main characters. These are
just secondary characters. But as you
can see for both Nano Banana models,
they were able to understand and
generate all of these characters really
well. So, first let's inspect Nano
Banana 2. I can't really spot any errors
with this. It can generate everyone very
well. And it looks like it put them in
some anime expo 2024. Pretty cool. It
even got the fingers correct. So, you
can see that actually Kenny and Bart
Simpson only has four fingers, which is
what they actually have in the real
cartoon. And then here we have Nano
Banana Pro. And again, it got pretty
much all the characters correct. I can't
really spot any flaws with this. So
overall, I would say it's a pass and a
tie between both models. All right,
next. Here's a test on how good it is at
generating tricky expressions. This
still trips up even the top image
generators out there. So here we have a
4x4 grid of a young female with these
emotions. From left to right, top to
bottom, we have happiness, awe,
enthusiasm, confidence, sadness,
jealousy, irritation, embarrassment,
surprise, confusion, nostalgia, fear,
love, relief, pride, and anticipation.
So let's review Nano Banana 2 first. She
does look happy. This does look awe. The
first row looks very good. She does look
like each of these emotions. Even the
confidence one, which is pretty tricky.
It rendered this very well. And then for
the second row, we have sadness,
jealousy, irritation, embarrassment. And
even for these three, jealousy,
irritation, and embarrassment. It also
rendered these very well. And then for
the third row, we have surprise,
confusion, nostalgia, and fear. It's
also really good. Like she does look
confused here. And this does look like
nostalgia. And then for the last row, we
have love, relief, pride, and
anticipation. For love, I'm not sure if
this really looks like love. Let me know
in the comments below. This one looks
really good. She does look relieved. And
I guess this does look like pride.
Anticipation looks very good. And then
here we have the previous Nano Banana
Pro. So for the first row, it's very
good. Here's the second row. Jealousy
looks kind of weird. I wouldn't say it's
as good as Nano Banana 2. For the third
row, all of these look pretty good. And
then here's the last row for love and
pride. Let me know in the comments if
this actually looks like love and pride
to you. For relief, this does look
pretty accurate. And then same with
anticipation. So overall, both of them
are decent. But if I had to pick a
winner, I would have to go for Nano
Banana 2. It looks just slightly more
realistic for some expressions,
especially for jealousy and awe. All
right, here's an even trickier test. I
got it to make a 4x4 grid featuring
Pokémon with these Pokédex numbers. And
here's what I got. Now, interestingly,
even though I got it to make a 4x4 grid,
Nanobanana Pro kind of hallucinated and
gave me a 3x5 grid instead. So, it
messed this up pretty badly. But
anyways, let's go over Nano Banana 2
first. So, 07 is Squirtle and then 18 is
Pidgeot. These are all correct and they
also look correct. And then for the
second row, these are also correct. Now,
for the third row, 2011 is really tricky
because this is unknown. So there's
actually an unknown for each letter of
the alphabet. Here it says the label is
unknown A. But if I Google what unknown
A looks like, it should look like this.
So this one is actually wrong. Again,
this is a really tricky prompt. I don't
expect it to get it 100% correct. And
then for the last row, we also have an
error for this one, Cascoon, which
should actually look like this. So Nano
Banana 2 completely messed this up. So
it got two out of the 16 wrong. Now, the
previous Nano Banana Pro didn't do too
well either. So, again, it hallucinated
and gave me a 3x5 grid. So, it has
repeats here like gold duck and
apparently. So, this is completely
wrong. And then it also added this extra
grimer here, which is really weird. And
then for unknown, let me just double
check if there is an unknown with this
shape. And it doesn't look like anything
in this diagram. I was expecting it to
be a K or an F, but this looks slightly
off. So that's also a fail. However, it
did get Cascoon correct over here. So I
don't know. I would say it's a tie
between these two models. Both of them
were not able to get unknown correct.
The new Nano Banana 2 wasn't able to get
Cascoon correct, but it was able to
follow my 4x4 grid instruction in the
prompt. Whereas for Nano Banana Pro, it
did not give me a 4x4 grid, but it got
casc. So there's pros and cons to each.
All right, here's another cool test on
its world understanding. Here I got to
make a highresolution where's Waldo
image. It should be very complex and
filled with meme characters. Waldo
should be hidden somewhere in the image.
So here's what we got from Nano Banana
2. You can see a ton of meme characters
in this image, including this rainbow
cat plus Doge over here. Meme coins,
plus all these different meme
characters. This is really cool. And it
did insert Waldo in the photo, although
he isn't really hidden. And then I guess
we have an extra Waldo clone here, which
isn't really correct, but anyways, that
is Nano Banana 2. You can see that it
has a really good world understanding of
all these meme characters. And then
here's what we got from Nano Banana Pro.
Also really impressive. And it did
insert Waldo somewhere in the image. So
I would say both of these are okay. But
in terms of the quality and how similar
it is to an actual Where's Waldo image,
I would have to give the point to Nano
Banana Pro. This looks a lot more
detailed and complex and it resembles a
Where's Waldo image a lot more. Let me
know in the comments what you think. All
right, here's another really tricky
prompt, which I don't expect it to get
100% correct. So, here's a grid of the
six most endangered frogs in the world
with their scientific name and a short
description at the bottom of each photo.
So, here is what I got from Nano Banana
2. The first one it gave me is a
mountain chicken frog. I have not heard
of this frog. This looks super normal to
me, but let me just Google its
scientific name really quickly. And
would you look at that? There is a
leptodactylus phallax frog and it is
called the mountain chicken frog and it
is critically endangered and it does
look like this. And then next up we have
this Panameanian golden frog. Let me
again Google this really quickly. And
here's our result. It does look like
this. It is called the Panameanian
golden frog. And this is critically
endangered and possibly extinct in the
wild, which is very sad. But there you
go. This is also correct. Now, next one,
we have this ticky kaka water frog,
which looks like Oh my god, what is it
doing? Anyways, it should look something
like this, I guess. Now, this is
endangered. It's not critically
endangered. I'm not sure if it's like
part of the top 10 most endangered frogs
out there. I would say the photo doesn't
look exactly like the real thing. And
then next we have this golden Mantela
frog which indeed exists and pretty
cool. It has a golden form and a red
form. It has an extremely restricted
distribution and so here it lists it as
endangered. So apparently it's only
found in this tiny part of Madagascar.
Pretty crazy. So this does look correct.
And then we have Archie's frog from New
Zealand. And here's what it looks like
in real life. And this is critically
endangered. So, I guess going back to
this photo from Nanopanana, it looks
kind of similar to the real thing. I
wouldn't say it's like 100% correct. And
then finally, we have this Kihanzi spray
toad, which looks like this. And this is
extinct in the wild. Very sad. Again, I
wouldn't say this looks like the real
thing. Here are some additional photos.
The real frog looks a lot more yellow.
So, I would say it got like the
descriptions and the names correct, but
in terms of the photos, it's not that
good. And I don't expect it to get this
correct. This is a really tricky prompt
because an AI model needs a lot of
existing data to know and generate that
thing. But if we have these critically
endangered species with only a few
photos, then it's really hard for an AI
to actually understand and generate this
from scratch. Anyways, here is the
generation from NanoPanana Pro. And
interestingly, it gave me like four
different frogs compared to the
generation from Nano Banana 2. So, this
panameanian golden frog we've gone over
before. And then we have this cycinillaa
Andes frog which apparently is so rare
that there's not even any information
about this. And then we have this
midwife toad which looks like this and
this is endangered and it's only found
in small parts of this tiny island
somewhere in the world. Now I wouldn't
say this image looks exactly like the
real thing. So this is wrong. And then
we have this Alcatraz snouted tree frog
which is critically endangered and it
looks something like this. I would say
it's pretty close. And then this one
we've gone over already. And then we
have this Hamilton's frog which looks
like this. And apparently this is
vulnerable globally but nationally
critical. And it's only found in like
these small islands in New Zealand.
Pretty crazy. Now it looks something
like this. So again, it's not like
entirely correct, but it's pretty close.
Anyways, it's a tough call here. Let me
know in the comments which one you
prefer. Now the awesome thing about Nano
Banana Pro is you can upload multiple
images and get it to edit those images.
So here I'm testing to see if it can
help me do homework. Here, I'm going to
upload this worksheet of an animal cell.
And for the prompt, I got to fill in the
blanks and use messy handwriting so it
looks like I actually did it. So, here's
what I got from both models. Here's Nano
Banana 2. And as you can see, it can get
some stuff correct, but not all of them.
So, for example, mitochondri.
And then cell membrane, it also got
correct. Same with cytoplasm, GG
apparatus, and then rough endopplasmic
reticulum, it also got correct. However,
it also labeled some of them completely
wrong. So, for example, this one here
should be the nucleus, not the
nucleololis. And then this one here
should be the nucleololis, not the rough
ER. And then here's what I got from the
previous Nano Banana Pro. And I would
say it got even more stuff wrong. So,
for example, here it labeled the cell
membrane to be the nucleololis, which is
just absolutely horrible. And then here,
this should be the cytoplasm, but it
labeled it the cell membrane. In terms
of having the fewest errors, I would say
Nano Banana 2 did a better job. However,
note that for some strange reason, it
turned this into like a photo copy. This
looks like a photo of this worksheet,
whereas for Nano Banana Pro, it retained
the original white background. All
right, maybe biology was too hard for
it. So, here I uploaded this math
assignment and also got it to solve
these problems with messy handwriting.
And here's what I got from Nano Banana
2. You can see it does look like I wrote
this. It even added this part over here
as if I cross this out to make this look
more natural. Pretty sneaky. And then
here is Nano Banana Pro's generation.
This is also really good. This also does
look like the answers are handwritten.
However, it got a lot more errors with
this generation. For example, here it
repeated this divide by 4.8 twice, which
is not correct. We only need one line.
And then over here, this is also wrong.
Whereas you can see for Nanoban 2, it's
actually able to show my work a lot more
correctly. So, in this instance, I would
have to give the points to Nano Banana
2. I've been covering the best image and
video generators, and it can get very
overwhelming. Fortunately, Higsfield,
the sponsor of this video, brings
everything together all in one place.
You can use the best image and video
models all in one integrated platform.
They're usually the first to release
models when they come out, and Nano
Banana 2 is already available on their
platform. Simply click on image and then
Nanobanana 2 to start creating. And they
just launched Higsfield Soul 2, their
own foundation image model built
specifically for creative, fashionware,
culture native image generation. This
isn't just a general purpose image
generator. Soul 2 is designed to give
you aesthetically awesome images. Let me
show you how this actually works. So
inside Higsfield under image, simply
click on soul 2. And here you can just
enter a text prompt and then also select
the aspect ratio and the resolution. Or
if you want more control, Soul Reference
lets you upload an image and generate
new variations that feel like they
belong to the same visual world. And it
doesn't stop there. Because Soul 2.0 is
built to be the foundation of your
creative process, it pairs really well
with other tools inside Higsfield like
Nano Banana Pro. The idea is simple.
Generate your image in Soul 2.0 first.
Nail the lighting, composition, and
aesthetic, and then bring it into Nano
Banana Pro for editing. The stronger
your bass, the better everything
downstream looks. Sold 2.0 currently
comes with 20 curated presets, things
like Y2K, editorial, street style, old
smartphone, and more. These are fully
trained aesthetic directions that act as
creative starting points. It understands
fashion culture, camera mediums, and
even posing. You get more natural body
language, better physics, and editorial
quality results. Try Nano Banana 2, Soul
2.0, know and other top models on
Higsfield today. Click the link in the
description below. All right, here's an
even harder test. So, I uploaded this
image and I got it to put this image
into four quadrants. For the first
quadrant, it needs to be an infrared
thermal map of the photo. For the second
quadrant, it should be a segmentation
map of the photo. For the third
quadrant, it should be a depth map. And
for the fourth quadrant, the photo
should have inverted colors. So, first
of all, here's what I got from Nano
Banana 2. For this infrared map, it's
actually pretty good. So indeed her skin
should be warmer than for example her
dress plus this sofa. But she should
also be emitting heat. So like parts of
the sofa where she's touching should be
more yellow which is indeed correct. I'm
not sure why it's making her eyes and
then her knees here white though. So the
white part is an error for the windows
in the background. They should be a lot
cooler and that's why these are darker
in color. So the infrared map is like
80% correct. Here is the segmentation
map. This is pretty good. Here's the
depth map. This also looks pretty good.
And then here is the inverted pictures.
So if I invert the colors, while this is
close, these aren't the original colors
of the photo, which should look like
this. So again, not entirely correct
here. And then here is Nano Banana Pro's
generation. For the heat map, it's
pretty good. However, one slight error
here is that maybe the dress should
actually be lighter in color. So in that
case, I would have to give the point
more to Nano Banana 2. And then here's
the segmentation map. Here's the depth
map. And then here is the inversion. Let
me invert the colors again. And here is
the original photos. So again, not
entirely correct here. Anyways, this is
a really tricky prompt. Let me know in
the comments which one you prefer. All
right. Next, here's a tricky prompt that
no image generator has gotten correct so
far. So, the prompt is 11:15 on a clock
and a wine glass filled to the top. For
Nano Banana 2, it's not really clear
which hand is the minute hand and which
is the hour hand. So, I mean, at least
to me, this one looks shorter. So, it's
like showing 255 instead of 11:15. And
then the wine glass is also not filled
to the top. Very disappointing. And then
here is Nano Banana Pro. The wine glass
is filled to the top. However, it failed
to generate 11:15. It was very close,
but the hourhand should be a quarter
past 11 and not exactly at 11. So, both
are not good, but in terms of the least
amount of errors, I would have to give
the point to NanoBanana Pro. All right.
Next, I uploaded this manga page and got
it to colorize and translate this to
Chinese. So, here's what I got from Nano
Banana 2. The Chinese looks perfect, and
the colorization is also really good.
It's also able to detect that this dude
is called Red Hair Shanks and then color
this guy's hair red. And then here is
Nano Banana Pro. It also got the Chinese
and the coloration correct. But you
know, an interesting difference here is
that for Nano Banana 2, it decided to
translate this into traditional Chinese,
whereas for the Pro version, it
translated it into simplified Chinese.
Very interesting. All right. Next,
here's a test on its spatial
understanding. So, I uploaded this floor
plan, and here's my prompt. Based on
this floor plan, generate a photo of
this room from the main door. So, not
only does it need to analyze the spatial
configuration of this room, but it also
needs to understand where the main door
is, which is over here, and generate a
photo from this corner. Now, here's what
I got from Nano Banana 2. Unfortunately,
this is not correct. There are some
errors with this. For example, the
bathroom should be in this corner and
not over here. And then there should be
sofas and plants over here in the
foreground instead of on this left wall.
The piano is also facing the wrong
direction. It should be facing the lower
right corner instead. So, a lot of
errors with this generation. It does not
look like the floor plans configuration
at all. And then here is Nano Banana
Pros generation. It was able to get the
configuration of things more correct,
but this wasn't a photo of the room from
the main door over here. So, ideally, I
would wanted to make a photo of this
room taken from this corner. However, it
did get more details correct. For
example, the round bed plus the piano
should be facing the lower right corner.
Plus, the sofas and plants here are also
correct according to this original floor
plan. So, in terms of having fewer
errors, I would have to give the point
to Nano Banana Pro. Now, here's a test
on the reverse. Here, I got to make a 2D
floor plan of this room. And then I
uploaded this image. Here's what I got
from Nano Banana 2 and everything looks
pretty good. the configurations of the
plants and the sofas plus the TV screen.
Everything looked correct to me. Now,
interestingly, for Nano Banana Pro, this
one had more errors. For example, it
added two additional sofas here which
did not exist in the original photo.
Plus, the plants in the foreground are
also not correct. So, here I would have
to give the point to Nano Banana 2. Now,
Nano Banana is also extremely good in
converting data tables into charts. So,
for example, I can just upload this data
table and then prompt it to turn it into
a nice chart. You can decide the best
type of chart to use. And here's what I
got from Nano Banana 2. And the numbers
are actually correct. So, if I compare
like the first two bars here, the total
sample size is 88, which is correct. And
then we have 5 50 28 2 and 3, which is
what we have here. And then for this RR
percent, it's 62.5, which is correct.
And then for fullf fox the sample size
is 52 which is correct. Then we have 2
26 212 and 1 which are correct over
here. And then we have 53.8 which is the
RR percent which is correct. It even
added a nice legend at the bottom plus
some nice styling for this chart.
However, if you look at the third row
then here is where it starts to fall
apart. So here the sample size is 7
which is correct but then it should be 2
3 1 0 1. However, as you can see here,
the size of these bars are way too tall.
So, this should be way smaller in size.
Now, if you compare this same bar with
Nano Banana Pro, it actually got this
correct. So, indeed, it should be 2 3 1
and 1. So, this is actually a lot better
than Nano Banana 2. In terms of accuracy
and the least amount of errors in this
instance, I would have to give the
points to Nano Banana Pro. All right, so
that sums up my series of really
challenging tests. Hopefully that gives
you a sense of the strengths and
weaknesses of Nano Banana 2 and how it
compares with the previous version. Here
are some additional examples from
Google. Here we can get it to generate a
flat lay infographic depicting the water
cycle and it's able to generate this
pretty much flawlessly. With both models
of Nano Banana, you can input multiple
reference images. So here they're
inputting like 14 reference images into
the same photo and it's able to generate
this very well. You can of course also
use Nano Banana to crop or outpaint or
change the aspect ratio of an existing
photo. Next, let's go over the specs of
Nano Banana 2 and why this is so good.
First of all, note that Nano Banana 2 is
based off of Gemini 3.1 Flash, whereas
Nano Banana Pro, the previous version,
was based off of Gemini 3 Pro. There's
pros and cons of each, right? For this
one, it's the latest 3.1, which is
better than 3.0, but it's also flash and
not pro. So this is more designed for
speed whereas the pro version is
designed for quality. Now if you've been
using Nano Banana Pro then definitely
one of the main disadvantages is you
have to wait a long time for it to
generate an image. Whereas for this new
Nano Banana 2, it can generate an image
in only a few seconds. So it's way
faster while having very similar quality
and understanding. Here are some
additional specs for your reference. So
this can maintain character resemblance
of up to five characters and the
fidelity of up to 14 objects in a single
prompt. It also has enhanced instruction
following as you can see from some of my
tests. So it's really good at prompt
adherence. You can generate photos in
multiple aspect ratios and resolutions
from 512 pixels all the way to 4K
resolution. The really awesome thing
about Nano Banana 2 is they've added
four new aspect ratios. 4:1, 8:1, and
vice versa. So, this allows you to
create some super long panoramic photos
like this, which aren't possible with
earlier versions of Nano Banana. Now,
the awesome thing is they've released
Nano Banana 2 already, and you can use
it for free across Google's platforms
right now. So, here it says if you're
using the Gemini app, then Nano Banana 2
will replace Nano Banana Pro across the
fasting and pro models. In other words,
on the Gemini app, if you click on
create image, it automatically uses the
latest NanoBanana 2 already. And
apparently in AI mode, when you're using
Google search, you also have access to
Nano Banana 2. For example, if you're
doing a Google search, well, you can
click on this AI mode to basically pull
up Gemini to answer the question for
you. And then over here, you can prompt
it further to, for example, generate an
infographic or any other image from this
topic. and it would proceed to use Nano
Banana 2 to generate an image for you.
So, here's what I got. How cool is that?
So, you can get Gemini to do a Google
search on a specific topic first and
then get Nano Banana to create an image
on your topic. Really cool. Everything
is seamlessly integrated into this AI
mode in Google search already. Now, in
addition, you can also use this via
Google's AI Studio. So, it's just a
studio.google.com, which I'll link to in
the description below. And here is where
you can click on image generation and
then use the new Nano Banana 2. Now here
it says you do need to link a paid API
key to access Nano Banana 2 via this AI
studio platform. But the advantage of
this is you can control a lot more
settings like temperature, the aspect
ratio, the resolution. Notice that this
is up to 4K. Plus you can also control
the thinking level as well as turn on
grounding with Google search. So it can
actually do a web search for accurate
and relevant information before
generating your image. So those are the
main platforms where you can use the
latest Nano Banana 2. Now how good is
this compared to the other leading
models? Well, as you can see from this
independent leaderboard called
artificial analysis, Nano Banana 2, at
least the initial ELO score is actually
ranked number one, at least for text to
image, well above GPT Image 1.5 and Nano
Banana Pro. And if you look at the API
pricing of this, notice that this is
like two times cheaper than Nano Banana
Pro. So it's way cheaper and faster and
on average you get a better quality
generation. Now this is just the text to
image leaderboard. Next, if you look at
image editing, this is where you upload
an image for it to edit further. Then
interestingly, Nano Banana 2 actually
ranks below Nano Banana Pro. And as I
showed you from some of my tests, I also
get a similar vibe. It's not as
accurate, especially if you get it
sueedit some really complex stuff with a
lot of text or data. Anyways, that sums
up my review of Nano Banana 2. This is
currently one of the best models you can
use right now, and this is way faster
and cheaper than the previous Nano
Banana Pro model. It's already out and
free for you to use on the Gemini app.
So, definitely give it a shot, and let
me know in the comments what you think
of it. What other cool stuff were you
able to get it to do? Thanks for
watching and if you enjoyed this video,
remember to like and subscribe. And if
you've made it to here, I've got a treat
for you. I'm partnering with Nvidia to
give away an RTX 5090 GPU around their
GTC 2026 event. With this, you can
easily run AI tools locally on your
computer. Here's how to enter. Simply
click the link in the description to
register and attend at least one GTC
2026 session, which will be on March
16th to 19th. you can attend virtually
or in person. Here are some of my
favorites. Jensen Huang's keynote is an
obvious one, but this one on humanoid
robots at scale as well as this one on
openw world models are also on my watch
list. Again, make sure you sign up for
GTC using the link in the description
below and then afterwards fill out the
form and you're good to go. It's totally
free to